THE NEW NUMBERS "QUITE STRANGE."
JOHN?
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
CHINA RESTRICTED TRAVEL INSIDE
OF WUHAN.
COULDN’T TRAVEL TO OUR AROMA
WUHAN IF YOU LIVED IN CHINA, NOT
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
REMEMBER, WHILE IT WAS SPREADING
IN CHINA, MULTIPLE NEWS OUTLETS
REPORTING IN FEBRUARY, THERE WAS
A VIDEO, ACTUALLY, SHOWING
PEOPLE IN CHINA BEING FORCIBLY
DRAGGED FROM THEIR HOMES AND
ALSO QUARANTINED.
WE HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY THAT VIDEO,
NOW IN LIGHT OF BRET BAIER’S,
AND ALL OF HIS EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING, WE NEED ANSWERS IF
WHAT IS BEING REPORTED BY OTHER
PEOPLE IN FACT IS TRUE.
I WANT TO KNOW IF THAT VIDEO IS
ACCURATE.
WHAT DID WASHINGTON DO -- WHAT
CAN THEY NOW DO TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE?
WHAT CAN THEY DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM FUTURE
PANDEMICS?
HERE TO EXPLAIN THAT, A GUY WHO
KNOWS HOW TO DEAL WITH TOUGH
TIMES.
FORMER NEW YORK CITY’S MAYOR,
RUDY GIULIANI.
MR. MAYOR?
>> I TRIED TO BRING PEACE
BETWEEN CUOMO AND THE PRESIDENT.
HE GOES OUT AGAIN.
I NEED, I NEED.
I TRIED.
WHY DON’T YOU ASK PRIVATELY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE TOLD ME
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERED FOR NEW YORK.
THEY PICK UP THE CALL.
HOW DO WE OPEN YANKEE STADIUM
QUESTION MIKE I HAVE MY PLAN,
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
>> I LIKE THE IDEA OF CHECKING
PEOPLE WHO GO.
IT MAY BE WITH HALF OF A STADIUM
OR A THIRD OF A STADIUM.
I OPENED BROADWAY FOUR DAYS --
THREE DAYS AFTER SEPTEMBER 11TH.
IF THEY DIDN’T WANT TO OPEN.
I SAID TO THEM, I WILL PROTECT
EVERYBODY THAT COMES IN, I WILL
PROTECT ALL OF THE ACTORS,
ACTRESSES, THE BAND, THE WHOLE
THING.
THE FIRST NIGHT, THERE WAS MAYBE
A THIRD OF AN AUDIENCE.
A SECOND NIGHT, ABOUT A THIRD OF
AN AUDIENCE, BY NEXT WEEK, IT
WAS WELL AGAIN.
YOU START WITH 20,000 PEOPLE IN
THE STANDS.
SPREAD THEM OUT.
AT LEAST THEY WILL BE ON
TELEVISION.
IF I CAN WATCH A GAME ON
TELEVISION, IT WOULD BE LIKE
BEING IN HEAVEN, FOR ME.
WAS SEAN, LAWYER.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE OUR
JUDGE HIT A HOME RUN
>>>> Sean: I’VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF GOING TO A GAME WITH YOU.
DO YOU HAVE THE BEST SEAT IN THE
HOUSE, RIGHT NEXT TO THE YANKEE
DUGOUT.
HERE’S THE THING, CAN WE -- >>
60s IN PARK.
>> Sean: YOU WILL LIKE THAT
BETTER.
I TALK ALL THE TIME
HERE’S THE DEAL.
IF PEOPLE WITH UNDERLYING
ILLNESS OR COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS, THEY’VE GOT TO TAKE THE
SEASON OFF.
I THINK WE AGREE.
IF THEY GET IT TEMPERATURE
CHECK, EVERYBODY ELSE WEARS A
MASK, AND YOU DRINK BEER THROUGH
A STRAW, YOU EAT HOT DOGS, YOU
CAN EAT PEANUTS OR POPCORN, I
THINK MOST NEW YORKERS WOULD
VOTE TO GO.
THAT’S MY VOTE.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO DO, I’VE SAID
THIS NOW FOR ABOUT A WEEK.
WE HAVE TO GET SOMETHING
STARTED.
WHATEVER COMPROMISE WE HAVE TO
MAKE IT TO GET IT STARTED, LET’S
MAKE IT.
IF IF YOU WANT TO PLAY A
BASEBALL GAME WITH ONLY 20,000
PEOPLE IN THE STANDS, MAY BE
NOBODY IN THE STANDS FOR A
WHILE!
JUST PUT IT ON TELEVISION.
THEN WE STOP BRINGING PEOPLE
END.
WE’VE GOT START GOING BACK.
LET’S DO A BROADWAY PLAY, LET’S
STREAM IT -- LIVE STREAMING.
PAY TO WATCH IT.
THE ACTORS COME IN, THEY CAN ALL
BE SCREENED -- >> Sean: IF YOU
THINK --
IF EVERYONE GETS A TEMPERATURE
CHECK IT, AND I DON’T KNOW ALL
THE ANSWERS, I’M JUST THROWING
MY LITTLE IDEAS.
SAME WITH NEW YORK CITY, IF HALF
THE WORK FORCE STATES, NOW YOU
HAVE SOCIAL DISTANCING IN EVERY
OFFICE.
IT TO GET INTO AN OFFICE, YOU
GET YOUR TEMPERATURE CHECK.
EVERYONE IN THE OFFICE, FOR A
WHILE, I KNOW IT SUCKS, YOU HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK, YOU HAVE TO WEAR
GLOVES FOR A SMALL PERIOD OF
TIME.
THAT WILL ALL GO AWAY AFTER A
WHILE.
YOU CAN OPEN NEW YORK CITY, YOU
CAN OPEN YANKEE STADIUM, AM I
WRONG?
>> YOU ARE NOT WRONG.
THE PLAN SHOULD
BE IMPLEMENTABLE OPENING.
IT’S LIKE IT BUILDS ON ITSELF.
I’VE WATCH THIS WITH
SEPTEMBER 11, FIRST TWO OR THREE
NIGHTS, NOBODY SHOWED UP.
NOTHING HAPPENED, AND THEN
PEOPLE SHOWED UP.
>> Sean: I WILL GO WITH YOU TO
THE FIRST GAME.
>> THE FIRST GAME, AND MIGHT
BE -- 10,000, 20,000 PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I’D BE LUCKY.
>> I WON’T BE TALKING THE WHOLE
TIME.
YOU’LL BE ABLE TO HEAR ME.
YOU’LL BE SIX SEATS AWAY.
>> Sean: I NEVER SHUT UP.
>> THE POINT THAT YOU ARE
MAKING, THAT I’M MAKING IS,
WE’VE GOT TO START MOVING
THINGS.
THINGS STARTED.
MAYBE EVEN IN A SMALL WAY.
JUST GET THEM STARTED.
A COUPLE OF BROADWAY PLAYS THAT
ARE STREAMED.
>> Sean: WILL NEW YORKERS
EXCEPT THAT TEMPERATURE THING
BEFORE THEY GO IN?
WILL THEY ACCEPT FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME WEARING A MASK?
I WOULD.
I DON’T SPEAK FOR ALL
NEW YORKERS.
>> I WILL SPEAK FOR 90% OF THEM.
DURING THIS LOCK-IN EVERY DAY OR
TWO I GO OUT TO MY CAR AND I
DRIVE AROUND.
I’VE BEEN TO BROOKLYN,
STATEN ISLAND, QUEENS, I WAS ALL
THE WAY OUT TO CONEY ISLAND, I
WATCHED NEW YORKERS.
THEY ARE COMPLYING.
THEY ARE COMPLYING!
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD.
A COUPLE OF MISTAKES, BUT VERY
SMALL IN A CITY OF A .3 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY DISCIPLINED.
VERY PROUD OF THEM.
LET’S COME BACK!
AND THEY GOT TO STOP OR WILL BE
CLOSED ON FOR ANOTHER SIX
MONTHS.
>> Sean: PLEASE TELL YOUR
FRIEND GOVERNOR CUOMO --
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID EVERYTHING
FOR NEW YORK.
HE DOESN’T HAVE TO DO IT
PUBLICLY!
DO IT PRIVATELY.
WORK TOGETHER.
EVERY TIME HE GOES I NEED, I
NEED, IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
>> THAT’S HOW HE DEALT WITH HIS
FATHER, HE SHOULD DEAL WITH
TRUMP THAT WAY.
CALL HIM UP PRIVATELY, DON’T
EMBARRASS THEM.
>> Sean: EXACTLY!
ESPECIALLY AFTER HE DELIVERED.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT GOVERNOR
WOULD ATTACK HIM THAT WAY EITHER
EITHER.
>> Sean: I WILL GO TO THE
FIRST GAME WITH YOU, YOU GET THE
BENEFIT OF NOT HEARING ME
CHATTING.
I’VE GOT A MASK ON, I’M 6 FEET
AWAY, YOU’RE LUCKY.
IT WILL BE GREAT.
>> CAN YOU YELL AT THE UMPIRE
THROUGH THE MASK?
THAT’S THE IMPORTANT PART.